what's happening yo this week on thug
notes we getting Riga with Hamlet by
William Shakespeare it's going back up
in the kingdom of Elsinore the old
King's brother Claudius gone and married
the Kings old breezy Gertrude and Queen
Gertrude son Hamlet getting all clunks
this is mom acting like a ho
things get straight stupid with some God
speed the ghost of old King Hamlet
creeping on the castle then them gods
holla at Hamline to tell him he got a
check this ghost so Hamlet step up to
his ghost daddy who tell him that his
brother Claudius was plotting on the
crown and straight up Isis ass
cold-blooded ghost daddy tell Hanley
that he got a strap up and put a toe tag
on that fool Claudius straight justice
now I mean back in the castle hammers
boo a filly again an earful from her
daddy Polonius and her brother Laertes
they say she need to steer clear of
Hamlet since he might just hit it and
quit it
Oh fill yourselves good looking out and
ignores all of Hamlet's Howard
so when have me acting cray-cray at the
thought of blocking Claudius everybody
just thinking lovesick later Hamlet
decides he's gonna put on a play that
red max out Claudius ghosted the old
king when Claudius sees his crime
happening on stage he books it for the
exes now heaven knows for show ghost
daddy been spitting the truth later
hammy rolls up to his mama crib when she
asks him why he'd be disrespecting the
king all the while Polonius behind and
listening in we're handling and Gertrude
get all up in each other's grill
Polonius screams like a [ __ ]
thinking it's that fool Claudius Hamlet
shakes that cat right through the
curtain oh now Larry's getting crunk
about Hamlet killing his father and
Ophelia starts losing her
so Claudius comes up with a plan that
lehrentv should dip its swords tipping
poison and challenge Hamlet to a duel
and if that don't work Claudia's gonna
put some poise in the hamlet swine now
if it gets even more real when the Queen
bus is in and says Oh Phil you don't
drown damn Aslan seasoned Hamlet bang
out the Queen ptosis - Hamlet
but accidentally slam some of that
poison juice then lera tease a hamlet
both stab each other with that poison
blade just then
Kaoru bites the dust and Lera T start
stitching at Hamlet how Claudia's be
trying to poison it so Hamlet staffs
Claudius and makes him drink from that
poison Cup mmm
lissa beaten haterade gotta have it in
the end the royal family are landed
sharp so the kingdom goes to some other
soldier boy named Fortinbras now all
throughout this play have it be all torn
up about the task of put away that
Claudius his dough and keeps the land
his procrastination is one of the most
debated subjects in all of Shakespeare
some Bartlett's think is because handed
be too much of a sensitive [ __ ] to
kicking in a world of gangsters playing
dirty on the street I just think that
Hamlet got mad oedipal complex up in his
mother his heavenly want to get freaky
with his marble he can't bring himself
to get the man who doing what he wanted
to kill his pop and get down with his
old lady some cats even think that
Hamlet just trying to buck the system
and bring down a crooked Kingdom over
floor with lies and treachery and
speaking of Lies you might have spotted
our bard Willy shakes slinging images of
skin disease all up in this easy when
Hamlet dissing his momma in act 3 he'd
be talking about the body of souls
authors places and blisters and in 5:1
the clown gravediggers be happen about
pocky corpses all this nasty ass is
showing how although these fools be
front looking righteous then got nothing
but ruin and corruption underneath now
you're just st. going hard in the paint
unless you feel lies how this play
catches the ambiguity of modernity like
the modern man hell it ain't got a clear
devotion to a cold in fact had to be
tripping up because of this divided mind
and will how's it brother gonna keep it
real on the street
what are these ethical and metaphysical
uncertainties my man we peeping out of
certainty and my boys famous to be or
not to be speech some oh jeez think the
speech me Hamlet can't decide whether he
want to live or die but my other
brothers think that he trying to choose
between the Christian ideal or denying
myself or spilling some blood the claim
is thrown but Hamlet ain't the only one
who'll be confused
and the play of life the bar going and
even cast us as characters of
uncertainty I mean check all these
uncertainties playing can we really
trust Hamlet's ghost daddy what's going
in on the whole thing can everybody see
the ghost in act 1 but only my boy
Hamlet in act 3
it's Hamlet just pretending to be crazy
or has his mad fiction become fact looks
like old Willie's gone and made Hamlet's
up a song yo I hope you feeling educated
today player tune in next week
[Music]